[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم محمود مراد
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع فيه احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره تاتيكم
من نيويورك وحديث في مجلس الامن بشان
تقرير البعثه الامميه في كولومبيا
والاوضاع السياسيه هناك وفي مواضيع الحصاد
هذه الليله
يختتم قمه يصفها بالتاريخيه في ليتوانيا
يقول انها جعلت اوكرانيا اقوى في مواجهه
روسيا واقرب الى الحلف مجموعه السبع تعلن
تقديم ضمانات امنيه طويله الامد لكييف
يقول ان الخطوه تحمل دلاله كبيره وتفتح
فرصا امنيه جديده لبلاده وموسكو تصف الامر
بالخاطئ للغايه وتقول انه بمثابه تعد على
امنها
بعد سجل مع كينيا واثيوبيا ترشق بين
الحكومه السودانيه والمبعوث الاممي
يكشف منعه من دخول البلاد ويقول للجزيره
ان الحكومه فقدت السيطره وفقدت ثقه دول
المنطقه والحكومه تتهمه بحمل مشروع يهدف
الى تفتيت البلاد وتقول انه فقد المنطقه
دبلوماسي والسياسي
ونائب المتحدث باسم غوترش يقول للجزيره ان
اي حل للازمه يجب ان ياخذ في الاعتبار دول
الجوار
بعد وقوع حادث امنيين على الشريط الحدودي
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه احبط محاوله
تخريب للسياج الامني او وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول انه تم ردع نشطاء تابعين
لحزب الله هي عرض لبنانيه باعتراف دولي
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني يقول ان
ضم اسرائيل الجزء الشماليه من قريه الغجر
لا يسكت عنه وينبغي تحريره وقوه
اليونسفيلد تصف الوضع بالحساس للغايه
وتدعو لخفض التصعيد
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا السجاله المستمره بين
الحكومه السودانيه وكل من كينيا واثيوبيا
على خلفيه تصريحات بشان ضروره تدخل اقليمي
في السودان خصوصا بعد تصريح جديد جاء هذه
المره من المبعوث الامي ورئيس البعثه
الخاصه في السودان
فولكس الذي قال ان الحكومه في الخرطوم
فقدت السيطره على البلد وفقدت ثقه دول
المنطقه المبعوث الاممي كاشف للجزيره انه
منع من دخول البلاد الحكومه السودانيه
بدورها اتهمته بحمل مشروع يهدف الى تفتيت
البلاد على حد تعبيرها لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا على
حضراتكم السؤال التاليه كيف سينعكس السجال
بين الحكومه السودانيه من جهه والمبعوث
الاممي من جهه اخرى على الصراع المستمر في
البلاد جاءت النتائج كالتالي 20% توقعوا
الدفع نحو مسار التفاوض 46% صوت لخيار
مزيد من الجمود بينما
ذهبت 34% من الاصوات باتجاه امكانيه تدخل
اقليمي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه لتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وصف الامير العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
قمه النيتو في العاصمه الليتوانيه
وقال انها جعلت اوكرانيا اقوى في مواجهه
واقرب الى الحلف واعلن النيتو حزمه
مساعدات لاوكرانيا لسنوات عده كما تعهدت
دول مجموعه السبع بضمانات امنيه طويله
المال المدى
نتائج قمه الناتو في فينيوس ليست افضل ما
كان يطمح اليه الرئيس الاوكراني خاب
املزكي بغياب جدول زمني لانضمام بلاده الى
الحلم لكن الحلفاء طمانينه بضمانات امنيه
طويله الامد
اعلنت دول مجموعه السبع اطارا لابرام
اتفاقات ثنائيه بينها وبين كييف تضمن
امدادها بالاسلحه لعشر سنوات
دول مجموعه السبع تطلق اعلانا مشتركا لدعم
اوكرانيا سنساعد اوكرانيا في بناء دفاع
قوي في البر والجو والبحر لاستقرار
المنطقه ولردع اي تهديد
الضمانات الامنيه مهمه جدا لشعبنا وهي
تمهد الانضمامنا الى الحلف وليست بديلا
لعضوياتنا فيه هي بالتاكيد نجاح مهم
يمكننا القول ان نتائج القمه جيده ولكن لو
تلقينا الدعوه للعضويه لكان ذلك مثاليا
هذا هو الاجتماع التاسيسي لمجلس الناتو
اوكرانيا مجلس يجتمع فيه الطرفان
ويتشاوران ويقرران كنظيرين متساويين خطوه
تجعل اقرب من الحلف اكثر من اي وقت مضى
الحلفاء واقر ايضا حزمه مساعدات لعده
سنوات تحقق مزيدا من الموائمه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه واسلحه الناتو
لا يمكننا ان نسمح ابدا لموسكو بان تقرر
من يمكنه ان يصبح عضوا في النيتو روسيا
كانت دائما ضد اي توسعه للحلف متى تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو هو امر يقرره
الحلفاء واوكرانيا وليس لروسيا امكانيه
نقده
يخفق العالم الاوكراني في كل شارع في
فيديوز ليتوانيا وجاراتها من دول البلطيق
تريد عضويه فوريه في الحلف الاوكرانيا
فالجناح الشرقي للنيتو هو خط مواجهته
الامامي مع روسيا عضويه وان كانت تبدو
حتميه في المستقبل الا انها تبقى مؤجله
الى موعد غير معلوم
في قمته هذه التي يصفها بالتاريخيه يكبر
الناتو بعدد اعضائه ويزيد من عديده وعودته
ويقترب اكثر من حدود روسيا لكنه يبقي
اوكرانيا على عتبته دون منحها العضوي على
امل ان تكون الضمانات الامنيه المقدمه
جسرا يقود الى انضمامها المستقبلي للحلف
الاطلسي محمد المدهون الجزيره
فينيوس
ومن فينيوس تنضم الينا
الباحثه في مركز اوروبا التابع للمجلس
الاطلسي وينضم الينا من موسكو
سيرجيستروكان الباحث هو المجلس الروسي
للشؤون الدولي مرحبا بكم الصيدلي بما
استحقت القمه ان توصف بالتاريخيه كما جاء
على لسان ستولتنبر والقاده الغربيين
الحقيقه اعتقد ان التقدم الاساسي والموضوع
الاساسي كان يرتبط بمستقبل علاقه حلف شمال
الاطلسي مع اوكرانيا ومع السويد وما اذا
كان الحلف سوف يقدم دعوه لاوكرانيا كي
تنضم لا اعتقد
على مراده بالنسبه البيان لم يحدد جدولا
زمنيا محددا بالنسبه الى دخول اوكرانيا
الحلف ولكنه حدد ضمانات امنيه على المدى
المتوسط والمدى البعيد واعتقدوا ان هذه
انباء صار بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا
شنت الحرب على اوكرانيا بمسوغات كثيره
اهمها منع تمدد حلف الناتو شرقا والاقتراب
من حدود روسيا الحاصل الان بعد هذه القمه
وادماج دول جديده في منظومه النيتو ان
النت تمدد شرقا واقترب كثيرا من حدود
روسيا فنلندا تحتفظ بخط حدود طويل جدا مع
روسيا هل هذا اعلان بفشل استراتيجيه موسكو
في الحقيقه انت على حق تماما ليس لدينا اي
ادوات لكي نمنع من خلالها توسع حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعد انضمامه فنلندا الى التحالف
ان عمليه ضم السويد هي على قدمنا وساق
بعدما رفعت تركيا معارضتها
لهذه العمليه طبعا هذا من بين التحديات
الجديده بالنسبه الى روسيا ولكننا لا
نتفاجئ بذلك لاننا راينا العمليه في طور
التقدم لذلك روسيا سوف تعيد النظر في
استراتيجيتها الاساسيه المرتبطه
بالحدود مع الدوله الجديده
المنضويه تحت لواء حلف شمال الاطلسي الا
وهي فنلندا وذلك من اجل تعزيز القدرات
العسكريه
على هذه الحدود بالاضافه الى منطقه
البلطيق
والحدود كما تفضلتم هي اكثر من الف كيلو
متر 1300 كم مع فنلندا وبالتالي نرى ان
حدود الروسيا مع
توسعت بضعفين وهذا من بين التحديات
الاساسيه ولكننا على استعدادا لذلك هذه
القمه ارسلت رساله قويه بان حلف شمال
الاطلسي جاهز وهو يود ان يواجه روسيا على
الامد الطويل لذلك يتعين علينا ان نعيد
النظر في استراتيجيتنا الدفاعيه وان لا
نسمح
للتحالف بان يكون لديه الافضليه بالنسبه
الى هذا الموضوع
هذه القمه اعتبرت روسيا تهديدا مباشرا
لدول النيتو الا يعد ذلك استفزازا لروسيا
واعاده للاجواء في اوروبا والعالم باسره
الى مرحله الحرب البارده
لا اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن استفزاز لروسيا
الحقيقه هي الواقع الذي نراه على ارض
الواقع الحقيقه هي ان روسيا
اجتاحت اوكرانيا حلف شمال الاطلسي لم
يواجه لم يدخل في حرب مع
حلف في حرب مع روسيا وروسيا لم تدخل في
حرب مع الناتو ولكننا لا نتحدث عن المره
الاولى التي تجتاح فيها روسيا دوله جارا
حصل ذلك في جورجيا في العام 2008 وحصل ذلك
في شبه جزيره القرم في العام 2014 و2022
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن توسع حلف شمال
الاطلسي حتى في بلدان تاريخيا هي حياديه
من مثل فنلندا والسويد هي تود ان تنضم الى
التحالف لان هذا التحالف يرفع من منسوب
الامان فيها طيار الاسلحه الغربيه المتدفق
على الجانب الاوكراني وكذلك الضمانات
الامنيه الجديده كل ذلك استفزازا للجانب
الروسي هذا متحدث عنه الخبراء على الاقل
حتى القبيل قمه النيتو ان هذا يمكن ان
يدفع الكريملين اذا ما وجد نفسه محاصرا
وفي وضع غير يعني غير جيد في هذه الحرب
ومسيرتها قد يدفعه الى اتخاذ اجراءات
استثنائيه من قبيل التي يهدد بها مسؤول
روتين رفيع هو السيد
لربما يفعلون ذلك ولكن مجددا هذا ليس في
مصلحه روسيا ولم يكن من مصلحه روسيا ان
تجتاح اوكرانيا رئيس الولايات المتحده
رئيس بايدن والرؤساء الاخرون اوضحوا بشكل
لا لبس فيه انهم ليس لديهم اي نيه بالدخول
في حرب مع روسيا لديهم كل النيه القويه
بحمايه كل شبر من اراضي الناتو يتعين على
روسيا ان تحترم ميثاق الامم المتحده وان
لا تجتاح دول الجوار وبالتالي وبكل تاكيد
سوف تقدم دول الغربيه الدعم والمساعده
التقنيه والفنيه والاسلحه والمساعدات
الاقتصاديه للتاكد من ان اوكرانيا سوف
تصبح مجددا دوله ديمقراطيه وامنه سيد
استروكان ازاء هذا الدعم الذي يبدو غير
محدود من الجانب الغربي لاوكرانيا وقول
موسكو انها ت راقب هذه القمه ومخرجاتها عن
كثب في تقديرك ما الاجراءات العمليه التي
ترد بها روسيا على هذا على هذا التطور
[موسيقى]
عندما استمع الى تصريحات تقول ان حلف شمال
الاطلسيه لا يدخل في حرب او نزاع مع روسيا
ولكنه سوف يدافع عن كل شبر من اراضي هذا
مبهم بالنسبه الي لدي سؤال واضح هل نحن في
نزاع مع الدول النيتو نحن في نزاع مع
اوكرانيا واوكرانيا ليست دوله عضو في
التحالف اذا ما الذي يقوم به النيتو في
اوكرانيا ان النيتو
ايضا روسيا عذرا للمقاطعه سيد ستروكان
اليس اليس من المنطقي ان يطرح السؤال على
النحو التالي ماذا تفعل روسيا في اوكرانيا
وليس ماذا يفعل النيتو في اوكرانيا
نعم نعم يمكننا ان نعود الى التاريخ
بالنسبه الى ما تقوم به روسيا في اوكرانيا
هي تقوم باجراءات استباقيه لكي تواجه
الهجمات التي
تمت لمده ثمان سنوات واستهدفت دون باس وتم
التجاهل هذه الهجمات من قبل الدول الغربيه
وسكان منطقه الدومباس عانوا الامرين بسبب
هذه الهجمات وبالتالي لم تتمكن روسيا من
الاستمرار بقبول ذلك عندما تطرحون السؤال
بالنسبه الى دور روسيا في اوكرانيا لربما
ايضا يطرح السؤال ما الذي كان تقوم به
اوكرانيا لثماني سنوات قبل بدء هذه
العمليه العسكريه ويمكننا ان نعود الى
التاريخ واتفاقيات ولكن بالعوده الى موضوع
الساعه عندما نتحدث عن نتيجه القمه
بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا طبعا
بريطانيا من الواضح انها لم تحقق اي شيء
تقريبا الرئيس زيلينسكي اوضح انه يذهب
ويود ان يستمع الى مهل زمنيه او جدول زمني
ولكنه لم يحصل على ذلك في حقيقه الامر وان
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي السيد
استوتنبرغ اوضح عندما قال ان المسار الذي
يؤدي باوكرانيا لانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي يقضي بان تربح اوكرانيا الحرب على
روسيا وبالتالي هذا يمكننا ان نقول عنه
نفاق بالنسبه الى الموقف مع اوكرانيا في
الوقت نفسه
بالوقت المتبقي عذرا للمقاطعه سؤالنا
للسيده ريتشل في تقديرك عقب هذه القبله
وصفت بالتاريخيه كيف تتوقعين ان تسير
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ما النتائج
التي يمكن ان تترتب على هذه القمه وهذا
الدعم الكبير المقدم لاوكرانيا
خلال الفتره المقبله هل يجلس الطرفان على
مائده التفاوض ام لا
لا اعتقد ان
كلا الطرفين على استعداد للجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات في القريب العاجل ولكن هذا
الامر يعود اليهما بالنسبه الى القمه ان
هذه القمه لم تقدم كل ما كانت تتمناه
اوكرانيا ولكن هناك بعض النقاط الايجابيه
الولايات المتحده فرنسا بريطانيا العظمى
وحتى المانيا كل هذه الدول ترسل اسلحه
ثقيله بشكل متزايد الى اوكرانيا في الاشهر
18 الماضيه بالاضافه الى بولندا والدول
الاخرى وهذا الدعم من الواضح انه سوف
يستمر مجددا نحن لا نتحدث عن دول لديها اي
رغبه بالدخول في حرب مع روسيا هذه دول
تساعد دوله ديمقراطيه بالدفاع عن اراضيها
شكرا جزيلا لك
الباحثه في مركز اوروبا التابع للمجلس
الاطلسي كانت معنا من فينيوس عاصمه
ليتوانيا شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفنا كذلك
من موسكو السيد سيلقي ستروكان الباحث
والخبير في الشؤون الدوليه في المجلس
الروسي شكرا لكما
الضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا علقت عليها
موسكو بانها امر خاطئ للغايه وخطير جدا
وبمثابه تعد على امنها لنتعرف على هذه
الضمانات
يغلق باب العضويه في وجه اوكرانيا في
الوقت الراهن على الاقل لكنه يفتح نوافذ
اخرى للتعاون تقدم مجموعه السبع خطه تشمل
ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا اهم هذه الضمانات
انشاء صندوق غربي للمساعدات الماليه طويله
الامد اضمن امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
الحديثه والمتطوره على المدى الطويل
بالاضافه الى الالتزام بتدريب الجنود
الاوكرانيين تهدف هذه الخطوات وفق
المسؤولين في النيتو الى ردع اي هجوم
مستقبلي وارسال رساله لروسيا بان الزمن
ليس في مصلحتها بمعنى اخر يقول النيتو
لروسيا ان علاقته مع اوكرانيا ستتعزز مع
مرور الوقت اما عن الطريقه التي ستنفذ
فيها هذه الخطه فستكون عبر اتفاقيات
ثنائيه بين مجموعه دول السبع واوكرانيا
على غرار العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل اذ تدفع الولايات المتحده
لاسرائيل مليارات الدول السنويا كمساعدات
امنيه وعسكريه تعتبر الولايات المتحده
المموله الاكبر ماليا في العالم باسرائيل
تبحث واشنطن عن استنساخ هذه العلاقه
الخاصه مع اسرائيل لتكون علاقات لمجموعه
السبع مع اوكرانيا اذ بلغت التزامات
الولايات المتحده اتجاه اوكرانيا حوالي 37
مليار دولار منذ بدايه الحرب اذا ما نفذت
هذه الخطه المقترحه فستتعزز قدرات
اوكرانيا العسكريه دون التزام الناتو بخوض
صراع مباشر مع روسيا ابرز مبادئ الناتو
تعتبر ان اي اعتداء على اي عضو هو اعتداء
على جميع الاعضاء بهذا يشكل الناتو مظله
لجميع البلدان الراغبه في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه المستمره حتى لو كانت
التفاصيل تختلف من بلد الى اخر ترحب
اوكرانيا لكنها تطالب بالمزيد امر اثار
استياء اكثر من مره التي تطمع بتقديم كييف
بعض الامتنان اما في لندن فيقول وزير
الدفاع بوضوح اظهروا بعض الامتنان نحن
لسنا امازون المزيد في نظر زيلينسكي هو
اسلحه بعيده المدى تعاهدت فرنسا بتقديم
بعض منها بعد التحفظ للغرب على تقديمها
حتى لا تضرب الاراضي الروسيه بها عليه
تتورط تلك الدول في الصراع بشكل مباشر رغم
كل هذه الحفاوه باوكرانيا في قمه النيتو
الا ان الاوكرانيين متحفظون على عدم وجود
جدول زمني لتنفيذ خطه الضمانات تلك هذا
امر عبثي غير مسبوق يقول زيلينسكي هكذا
يدخل العالم في طور اعاده تشكيل العلاقات
والتحالفات بعد عام ونصف من حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
ينضم الينا الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه دكتور عمر
مرحبا بك لماذا تعتبر موسكو الضمانات
الامنيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا بمثابه تعد على
روسيا كلها ما الفرق اصلا بينها وبين
المساعدات العسكريه والماليه المتدفقه على
اوكرانيا بالفعل منذ بدايه الحرب
وفقد تعهد طويل المدى لعشر سنوات وبين هذه
مساعدات ستستمر ولن تنقطع
وستتطور وسيدخل فيها اطول اخرى مثل الامن
السيبراني التدريب مستمر للجزئيات مستمره
مصادره بعض
الموارد الاموال والموارد الروسيه حتى
تقوم باعاده الاعمار مهما دمرت في
اوكرانيا فبالتالي يعني مدى طويل
ورغبه اوضح في في الدعم لكن هذا كله طبعا
يحتاج لسلوكيات لانه
اوكرانيا سلمت سلاح يعني اكثر من الف راس
نووي
في
1994 في
بمذكرات بودكاست على اساس ان حين تسلم هذا
تسلم هذا سلاح الدموي ستقوم روسيا
الاتحاديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمملكه المتحده بضمان امنها وبضمان
سلامه اراضيها واحده من الضامنين غازتها
في 2014 في القرم ثم بعد ذلك
والاثنين لم يفعله شيء في في 2014
فهذه يعني الضمانات طبعا الوضع تغير تماما
لكن
يعني رغبتهم في الانضمام النيتو بسبب هذا
التجربه التاريخيه في مثل هذه المعاهدات
هل السلاح النووي اصلا مطروح على الطاوله
في هذا الصراع في تقديرك يعني ربما
رهان هذه الضمانات الامنيه وتقديمها على
ان ان مثبت اعلان ان اوكرانيا نفسها طويل
لان من ورائها الغرب مستعد لامدادها بكل
هذه القدرات العسكريه والماديه لمده عشر
سنوات فهل موسكو تستطيع مجاباتها كل هذه
الفتره لذلك اسال مجددا هل النووي الخير
النووي اصلا الذي اتيت على ذكري مطروح على
الطاوله
لا لا اظن يعني احنا الان نحن بدانا من
اسلحه مشاه مضاده للدروع بدانا من المشكله
مشكله في في توصيل الجافلز في البدايه في
فبراير او قائد ربما قبل فبراير يعني كانت
هذه مشكله الان تطور الوضع بشكل كبير فصار
فاصلنا في المدرعات وفي المدفعيه ولكن
مثلا صواريخ
الاتراكز غير توجد اشكاليه فعند الولايات
المتحده
صواريخ كروز محموله جوا التي حتى يعني
اضطر الاوكران ان يطوروا بعض طائرات 24
طائرات قديمه اكبر مني سنا هذه اضطر انهم
يطوروها لكي تحمل هذه
الصواريخ الكروز الجديده التي بداها يصل
ربما يصل 500 كلم
ولكن
ليست كثيره ثمنها غير الغايه
فلم نصل بعد لمستوى يعني نقول سلاح
التقليدي الطويل المدى الذي يعني يطول
بالالف كيلومتر واكثر ولم نصل لمستوى
لمستويات حتى بعض الاسلحه التي يعني تحتاج
للدقه
العنقوديه سيكون لها تاثير اظن فربما اكثر
فاعليه حتى من طائرات ل 16 لانه بسبب
التخندق الروسي الموجود وبسبب حقول
الالغام التي
اوكرانيا بالفعل الا تستخدمها الا على
اراضيها هي خلال هذا الصراع دكتور عمر
القمه بدات وهناك حاله من النقمه الشديده
والمراره الواضحه تعتري خطاب الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلينسكي تجاهه دول الناتو
واتجاه الغرب بصفه عامه وانتهت بتمتع
بلاده بوضعيه مشابهه تقريبا للوضعيه التي
تمثلها اسرائيل بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
والغرب هل تعتقد ان في هذا الترضيه كامله
لا اظن ان الوضع هنا يتطلب الاتي هم
يريدون ان يكونوا جزء من النيتو لكي لا
يهاجمه بشكل في المستقبل
وتجربه بوتاسيوم مذكره
يعني تذكر دوما وبالتالي هم يريدون ان
يكون الدوله رقم بعد السويد دوله رقم 33
في النيتو وكان المامول من هذه القمه ان
يكون هناك جدول زمني واضح بتاريخ واضح
ربما 20 24 25 على اساس انه المامول ان
الحرب ربما تستمر سنه وبعد ذلك حين
يدخلونها تتوقف الحرب فاظن هذا كان السقف
العالي لتوقعات وهو ما لم يحدث ولم يكن
متوقع ان يحدث حقيقه وبالتالي نجد هذا
السجال يعني ما بين رئيس اللانسكي وما
ذكره
وبعض اساسا الغربيين وما ذكره ردا على ذلك
فيما خصل
دكتور عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اكد الرئيس الاوكراني فلونسكي ان بلاده
بحاجه الى الاسلحه العنقوديه الامريكيه
الصنع للدفاع عن النفس مشددا على حصر
استخدامها داخل اراضيها المحتله من روسيا
في المقابل قال الكريم اوكرانيا بذخائر
عنقوديه يغير الوضع ويجبر روسيا على اتخاذ
اجراءات مضاده حسب تعبيره
في الاثناء قال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ان الرئيس بايدن سيناقش مساله
تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى مع
الرئيس الاوكراني وسيواصل دراسه الامر كان
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني قد كشف انه على
اتصال بالمسؤولين الامريكيين بشان تزويد
بلاده بصواريخ
اتاكمز التي يصل مداها الى 300 كم من
جهتها نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان اداره بايدن تجري
نقاشا داخليا بشان الموافقه على ارسال عدد
محدود من صواريخ ارض ارض الى اوكرانيا
وفي مجال تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه الصنع قال مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي ان التدريب سيستغرق
بعض الوقت وبعد ذلك ستنقل المقاتلات على
الارجح الى اوكرانيا من الدول الاوروبيه
حسب تصريحه كان وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
قال انه تم تشكيل تحالف يضم احدى عشره
دوله لتدريب القوات الجويه على طائرات اف
16 من جهته اعلن السفير الاوكراني في لندن
ان 20 طيارا اوكرانيا سيتلقون التدريب على
المقاتلات في بريطانيا نهايه يوليو تموز
الجاري
تعد جبهه افدي افكا اكثر نقاط الجيش
الاوكراني تقدما في مقاطعه دونيتس رغم
احاطه القوات الروسيه للمدينه من ثلاث
جهات فان الجيش الاوكراني لم ينسحب منها
ويعمل على تصعيد هجماته ضد القوات الروسيه
لتخفيف الضغط عن قواته في جبهات المنطقه
الشرقيه مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج رافق
الجيش الاوكراني ورصد عمل وحداته في تلك
الجبهه
السرعه والبقاء في الخفاء بعيدا عن عيون
مسيرات العدو سمات اساسيه لعمل هؤلاء
المقاتلين الاوكران في واحده من اخطر
الجبهات الجنوبيه في مقاطعه
في هذه النقطه المتقدمه في جبهه افديفيكا
غربيه مدينه دونيتسك يدرك المقاتلون خطوره
الموقف لذا يبقون على اعدادهم قليله في كل
موقع
طائره مسيره تغنيهم عن فرق الاستطلاع كما
يقولون يرينا المقاتلون كيف رصدوا مواقع
الجنود الروس كل ما عليهم الان هو ادخال
الاحداثيات على هذا المدفع وضرب نقاط
المرصوده
كيلانا يستخدم المسيرات للرصد والكلين
ايضا حدود لا تستطيع المسيرات تجاوزها
والتركيزه على ايقاف التسلل ومسانده قوات
المشاه
نرافق الجيش الى موقع اخر من هذه الجبهه
هنا يستخدم الجنود سلاح الهاون للتصدي
للمشاه
لكنهم يشاركون في المعارك ايضا حين تتقدم
بعض الاليات يدرك المقاتلون قدم هذا
العتاد لكن الظروف كما قالوا تحتم عليهم
استخدام ما تقع عليه ايديهم
الوضع شديد التقلب هنا وحين يستخدم الروت
المدرعات يلجئوننا الى الاحتماء لكننا مع
هذا نضطر الى تطوير الهجوم المعاكس
بالتنسيق مع القطاعات الاخرى
يحرص المقاتلون على ابقاء الاشتباكات في
هذا القطاع بالذات مشتعله لمشاغله العدو
فافديفكا على مرمى حجر من عاصمه
الانفصاليين لذلك يبقون اعينهم مفتوحه على
تحركات الروس
ويرقضون كل خطواتهم مع احتدام المعارك في
مدينه باخموت مجددا تسعى القوات
الاوكرانيه للتصعيد في هذه الجبهه لتشتيت
جهود القوات الروسيه الشكوى من ضعف
امكانات وقله العتاد مستمره لكن الروح
القتاليه لهؤلاء المقاتلين تبدو بحال جيده
عمر الحاجه جزيره من مدينه افديفكا جنوب
[موسيقى]
الى ملف السودان حيث قال المبعوث الاممي
ورئيس البعثه الخاصه في السودان فولكر
بيرتس للجزيره ان الحكومه الحاليه في
السودان فقدت السيطره على البلاد وفقدت
ثقه دول المنطقه واكد بيرتس ان قرار حكومه
الخرطوم منعه من دخول البلاد امر يؤثر على
جهود البعثه هذا وقال مصدر في الخارجيه
السودانيه للجزيره ان السودان رفض المبعوث
الاممي لان مشروعه يهدف الى تفتيت البلاد
قائلا ان المبعوثه الاممي فقد المنطقه
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه على حد التعبير
المصدر وبينما اكدت الحكومه السودانيه
مشاركتها في قمه دول جوار السودان التي
تستضيفها مصر غدا الخميس تواصلت
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في مدن العاصمه الخرطوم
دخان المعارك في السودان ما يزال يحجب اي
افق سياسي ينهي النزاع الذي يوشك على طي
شعره الثالث
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
استمرت في مختلف مدن العاصمه الخرطوم
باستخدام شتى الاسلحه وبينما فرضت
بريطانيا عقوبات على ست شركات قالت انها
مرتبطه بطرفي النزاع اطلقت الامم المتحده
مزيدا من صيحات الفزع مؤكده ان الحرب
اجبرت اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين سوداني على
النزوح او اللجوء
ومع اطاله امد المواجهات ينذر المشهد
السوداني بعواقبه سياسيه اكثر خطوره فغياب
الحسب العسكري حتى الان وانهيار الهدى
وارتفاع الكلفه الانسانيه جلبت على
الحكومه السودانيه مزيدا من الانتقادات
الاقليميه والدوليه بلغت حد التشكيك في
شرعيتها وما يسمى بالحكومه الحريه
فقدت السيطره على البلد
فقره فقره سكره الدول المجاوره او الدول
المنطقه تصريحات المسؤول الاممي للجزيره
كانت ردا على بيان الخارجيه السودانيه
الذي اعلنت فيه رفض نشر اي قوات اجنبيه في
البلاد وهو مقترح اشارت اليه اللجنه
الرباعيه لمنظمه الايجاد خلال اجتماعها
ولان تلك اللجنه تمثل فعليا رافعه جهود
الاتحاد الافريقي بشان الازمه السودانيه
فان اخفاقها يبدو انتكاسه لمساعي انهاء
النزاع عبر اليه الحوار
فالحكومه السودانيه التي قاطعت اجتماع
ديسبابا اعتراضا على تراس كينيا للجنه
اصبحت بعد الاجتماع اكثر استياء بسبب
تصريحات الرئيس الكيني ورئيس وزراء
اثيوبيا عن فرض حظر جوي ونزع سلاح
المدفعيه الثقيله في السودان بالنسبه
للخرطوم يشكل ذلك محاوله لنزع الشرعيه عن
حكومتها وقد سارعت الى التلويح باعاده
النظر في جدوى عضويتها في منظمه الايجاد
وفي خضم تلك التجاذبات تستضيف القاهره يوم
الخميس قمه لدول جوار السودان في محاوله
وفق الرئاسه المصريه لوضع اليات فاعله
لتسويه الازمه سلميا وبالتنسيق مع
المسارات الاقليميه والدوليه الاخرى
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الاستاذ خالد
الايسر الباحث والمحلل السياسي السوداني
وينضم الينا من اديس ابابا السيد كارم
الباحث والمحلل السياسي المختص في الشان
الافريقي مرحبا بكما سيد خالد مرحبا بك
اهلا بك هذا التراشق غير المعتاد واللهجه
غير الدبلوماسيه التي يستخدمها المبعوث
الامامي من جهه التي تستخدمها الحكومه
السودانيه ايضا من جهه هل تعتقد انه يمكن
ان يؤثر على مسار الصراع الدائر داخل
السودان
التحيه لك ولمشاركم الكرام ولضيفك الكريم
التجليات الصراع الذي كان يدور خلف
الكواليس طوال الاعوام التي انقضت والذي
كانت تدير البعث الامميه عبر شعارات
مختلفه
ويتجلى في هذا الصراع المبعوثه الاموي
ادرك ان كل خطوه السابقه يعني ادخال
السودان في خضم حروب وليس ترسيخ القيم
التي جاء من اجلها بموجب قرار الامم
المتحده الذي يدعو الى الانتقال المدني
الديمقراطي السلم انتهى به الى فولكر الان
الى حاله من الحرب وبالتالي هو رجل لديه
تجارب في هذه العمليه ليس فقط في السودان
كانت له تجربه ايضا سوداويه في سوريا
لماذا لماذا الامر في نهايه المطاف
المبعوث الامامي هو معبر عن الجهه التي
بعثت او ابتعثته وهي الامم المتحده وليس
لديه موقف او يفترض انه ليس لديه موقف
شخصي ما الذي حمل الحكومه السودانيه على
الشخصنه هذا الامر
والاشاره الى انه ضيف غير مرغوب فيه او
مسؤول غير مروفي في بدايه يونيو المطلع
يونيو الماضي ذكرت الحكومه السودانيه هذا
وهل من الحكمه تحديد دور الامم المتحده في
صراع متقد كهذا وليس من الحكمه ايضا
التعدي على سياده الدول واستغلاليته
والسودان دوله لديها عضويه في الامم
المتحده
وقدمت ما يشفع لها من تبرير يتطلب تغيير
هذا المبعوث الاممي والشواهد كثيره لا
تحصى ولا تعد لكل الخروقات والاخفاضات
التي ارتكبها هذا الشخص تحديدا بدات منذ
ان اصطفى الى مجموعه قليله لا تعبر عن
في الخرطوم وجلس واستمع الى البرهان
وقيادات الدوله والخارجيه في اكثر من بيان
وفي اكثر من اجتماع اذا الرجل موقن في
استهداف السودان موغل في استهداف السودان
وليس بالرجل المناسب لكي يكون لدي جندات
تقديم الانتقال السلم السلس في السودان
معنا من الديس ابابا
الان السودان يعني اعرب وبلهجه قويه لا
تحتمل تاويلات عده عن رفضه لهذا المبعوث
الامي ومن قبله تحدث عن انه يحمل الاجنده
لصالح تعمل لصالح دول مجاوره هل تعتقد ان
هناك اصطفافا افريقا مع هذا المبعوث الذي
يرفضه السودان لتفتيت السودان فعلا كما
ياتي في الخطاب الرسمي السوداني
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الاستضافه بالنسبه الى
الوضع الراهن في السودان هو وضع
معقد ويؤثر ليس فقط داخل الحدود السودانيه
بين على كل المنطقه الافريقيه ولذلك هذا
هو السياق لعمل دول الجوار والامم المتحده
ودور المبعوث الاممي يجب ان يؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار وعلى محمل الجد لاننا نتحدث في
هذا السياق عن ازمه انسانيه قويه في
السودان
وايضا الاقتتال وطرفه
النزاع يستمران في الاقتتال ويرفضان
الجلوس الى المفاوضات يود كل منهما ان
يعزز ويرسخ السلطه التي لديها على حساب
مصلحه
الشعب السوداني وهذا يؤدي الى طباعه سلبيه
ليس فقط في داخل الحدود السودانيه بل على
كل دول المنطقه ولذلك يجب ان يؤخذ دور
الامم المتحده وبوت الامم المتحده على
محمل الجيب
عذرا للمقاطعه لماذا ايضا لا يؤخذ على
محمل الجد هذا التحفظ السوداني المتكرر
على شخص المبعوث الاممي في نهايه المطاف
هذا الرجل ليس معصوما من الخطا وهناك
سوابق لمبعوثين اماميين منهم من كان في
الجاره الشماليه ليبيا بالنسبه للسودان
منهم من ثبت بعد ذلك بالدليل القاطع انه
لم يكن محايدا ولم يكن نزيها بل كان
منحازا ويعمل لصالح اطراف اق ليميه وفي
تدخله في عمله يعني صفه المبعوث الاممي لا
تطفي على صاحبها في نهايه المطاف القداسه
والعصمه من الخطا
انا لا يمكنني ان اتحدث بالنيابه عن
المبعوث الاممي طبعا يمكن ان ترتكب
الاخطاء وقد تكون الاخطاء قدر ارتكبت في
السابق او ارتكبت في السابق ولكن
تمت الجهود على مستوى الامم المتحده
لمحاوله الوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار والى
وقف الاقتتال والاعمال العدائيه في
السودان ولكن طرفي النزاع لم يقبلا
بوقف المدفع والاقتتال اذا على المستوى
الشخصي انا لا اود ان اتحدث بالنيابه عن
المبعوث الاموي ولكن انا اتحدث عن الامم
المتحده وهي تعبر عن موقفها بالنسبه الى
اما حصل في اثيوبيا مؤخرا هذا يمكن ان
يشكل نقطه مرجعيه الحرب الاهليه استمرت
لسنتين واكثر من اصبحنا اليوم نعود الى
هذه النقطه تاتي اذا سمح الوقت بذلك
باختصار لو تكرمت لان الوقت المتبقي قصير
للغايه هل تتوقع الكثير من قمه دول جوار
السودان المنعقده غدا في مصر الخميس اخ
محمود لمجموعه من الاسباب الموضوعيه
والمغنيه على هذا الشعب السوداني وحتى
للاراده الاقليميه التي تريد ان تقدم
خدمات بدات واضحه ان عين الرضا في الواسطه
السودانيه ممثله في المجتمع السوداني
والحكومه السودانيه التي اصدرت بيان واضحه
هي هذه القضيه وعبرت عن دعمه لهذه اللقاء
توضح ان هذا اللقاء يرجى منه ان يكون
مفتاحا اساسيا للازمه لعده اسباب اولا
نوقف مصر ظل ثابتا منذ اليوم الاول ولم
يتغير ويحافظ على هويه الدوله السودانيه
محمد فكره ان تكون هناك مؤسسات سودانيه
محصنه ثانيا هذا اللقاء هو يمهد الطريق
لحوار السودان السودان يفتح افاق بين
القوى السودانيه فيما يصل الى حلول ناجعه
وغير ملزمه هذه القمه غير ملزمه وهذه
جزئيه مهمه وايضا اهم جزئيه تقطع الطريق
امام البيان الذي صدر من دول الايجاد بان
تريد ان ترسل القوات القوات ايساف الى
السودان الامر الذي رفضوا السودان بالامثل
فيبان صريحه ايضا هناك قضيه تشاركيه بين
كل الدول السبع بالاضافه للسودان ان قضيه
الامن القومي في هذه المنطقه التشاركيه
بين هذه الدول
وتساوت هموم التجار اثيوب عفوا ومصر وتشاد
وافريقي الوسطى وحتى جنوب السودان في فكره
ان هذا اللقاء يمكن ان يكون تمهيد يقطع
الطريق امام اي تدخلات دوليه انا اتوقع ان
تحدث هناك اختراعات كبيره ربما تنتهي
باجتماع الجيش مع الدعم السريع لحسم
القضيه فنيا وهذا هو المتوقع في غضون ايام
حسب تفسيري لمجريات الاحداث في السودان
وترجيع ميزان القوه العسكريه لص الجيش
السوداني ولكن دعني اجيب على ضيفك في
دقيقه واحده
يا محمود وتحدث عن ازمه انسانيه وهذا شعار
اصبح بيت الشعب السوداني للمتابع والنضيفك
هو رجل اعلامي متخصص في شان الافريقي لا
يفوت عليها ان الشعب السوداني يقف على رجل
قلب رجل واحد مع مؤسسته العسكريه ويعاني
في ظل معانا اقتصاديه وانسانيه ولكن زبط
الامم المتحده التي بامكان ان ترسل
مساعدات والاتحاد الافريقي يتفرجون على
عمل ان يلهوا زراعه السودان لكي يحقق
اجندتهم التي
الاوساط والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك على مشاركتنا هنا في الاستوديو
واشكر كذلك ضيفا من اديس ابا السيد كرام
تاتسي الباحث والمحلل السياسي المختص في
الشان الافريقي
في تعليق اخر قال فرحان حق نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده ان اي حل
للازمه السودانيه يجب ان ياخذ في الاعتبار
دول الجوار واضاف في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
تبعات الازمه في السودان واسعه النطاق وان
اعداد اللاجئين تزداد
اي حل للازمه في السودان يجب ان ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار دول الجوار التي تاثرت بشكل كبير
بتلك الازمه نحو 700 الف شخص غادروا
السودان ووصلوا الى دول الجوار الى مصر
وتشاد وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وجنوب
السودان وهذه البلدان يجب ان تشاركها في
الوصول الى حل للازمه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره في لبنان باصابه ثلاثه
اشخاص بجروح طفيفه في انفجار محدود عند
الشريط الحدودي الفاصل بين لبنان واسرائيل
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان مجموعه ممن
وصفهم بالمشتبه بهم حاولوا المساس بالسياج
الحدودي الامني من الجانب اللبناني وان
قوه عسكريه رصدتهم واستخدمت ما وصفها
بوسائل غير قاتله لابعادهم بينما قال وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان قوته رضعت نشطاء
تابعين لحزب الله حسب تعبيره من جهتها
اعلنت قوات الامم المتحده العامله في جنوب
لبنان انها تحقق في التقارير المتعلقه
بحادث وقع عند الخط الازرق جنوبي لبنان
وحثت كل الاطراف على وقف اي اعمال تؤدي
الى التصيد عند الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل
قال الامين العام لحزب الله اللبنانيه حسن
نصر الله ان هناك تعليمات لعناصر الحزب
بالتصرف في حال تعرض الجيش الاسرائيلي
للخيمتين اللتين نصبهما الحزب اخيرا في
مزارع الشبع واشار نصر الله في كلمه
بمناسبه الذكرى السابعه عشره لاندلاع حرب
2006 الى ان اسرائيل لا تجرؤ على التعرض
للخيمتين كما قال ان ضم اسرائيل الجزء
الشمالي من البلده الغجر لا يجوز السكوت
عنه ويجب العمل على تحريره
لم يجوا
على القيام بخطوه ميدانيه اتجاه الخيمه لا
لانه بساطه بيعرف انه هذا ما بينسكت عليه
ما اخذ الوضع الانساني للسكان ببلده الغجر
يجب ان يكون الموقف اللبناني حاسما هذه
عود لبنانيه وبيوت لبنانيه ويجب ان تعود
الى لبنان بلا قيد وبلا شرط ويجب العمل
على تحريرها هناك عدد من النقاط بتبلش من
البي 1
بتضلك ماشي لتوصل على
منطقه الغجر في نقاط
الاسرائيلي ما زال متواجدا فيها لم ينسحب
منها
ويجب ان يخرج منها هذه ارض لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
ما تسميه اسرائيل سياجا امنيا او تقنيا
تقيمه على امتداد الخط الازرق الذي يفصلها
عن لبنان لكنه لا يمثل اي حدود دوليه الخط
الذي رسمته الامم المتحده عام 2000 لتاكيد
انسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه من جنوب لبنان
يبلغ طوله
120 كيلو مترا بعد حرب تموز عام 2006
وصدور القرار الدولي رقم
1701 انتشر الجيش اللبناني الى جانب قوه
الامم المتحده المؤقته في لبنان اليونيفيل
في منطقه الجنوب البريطاني وصولا الى الخط
الازرق للمره الاولى يحصر لبنان المناطق
التي يختلف فيها مع اسرائيل عبر الخط
الازرق في ثلاثه عشره نقطه تمتد من مزارع
شبعه الى بلده راس الناقوره في قضاء صور
بمحافظه لبنان الجنوبي اما السياج التقنيه
الاسرائيلي المجهز بوسائل مراقبه
الكترونيه فامتد على طول الخط الازرق
ويتطابق معه في بعض الاماكن بينما اخرقه
في اماكن اخرى وهو وضع ترفض تل ابيب
تصحيحه لا يخلو الجنوب اللبناني عند
الحدود مع اسرائيل من توترات تنفجر بين
الحين والاخر بفعل خروق اسرائيل لقرار
مجلس الامن رقم الف وسبعمائه
زاد التوتر الحدودي الذي تركز في الاونه
الاخيره في مزارع الشبع ليشمل قريه الغجر
التي ضمها مشروع اسرائيلي لبناء جدار
اسمنتي محصن باسلاك شائكه
وزاره الخارجيه اللبنانيه اودعت شكوى لدى
الامم المتحده ضد اسرائيل على خلفيه ما
قالت انه تكريس لاحتلالها للجزء اللبناني
من القريه الحدوديه
انضموا الينا من بيروت الاستاذ ابراهيم
حيدر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي في تقديرك
سيد ابراهيم الى اين تذهب بجريات هذه
الجوله الاخيره من النزاع هل تعتقد انه
سيتلوها تصعيد ما بعد اصابه ثلاثه او اكثر
من عناصر حزب الله اللبناني على الحدود
نعم تحيه تحيه لك الحقيقه ان الحادثه الذي
حصل اليوم هو امتداد للتوتر القائم منذ ان
نصب يعني منذ ان كشف عن نصب حزب الله
خيمتين في منطقه مزارع شبعا وايضا الخرق
الاسرائيلي
لقريه الغجر او لشمال الغجر اللبناني لان
قريه الهجر هي قريه سوريه في الاساس
وبالتالي هي توسعت نحو الشمال اللبناني
التصعيد الحاصل حاليا هو تصعيد ضمن سقف
منضبط ولا يبدو ان يعني التوجه هو لتصعيد
شامل في المنطقه ما يجري هو محاوله جيش
نبض اذا جازت جاز التعبير ومحاوله رفع
شروط معينه ان كان فيما يتعلق
بالخيمتين في منطقه مزارع الجبعه
وفيما يتعلق بالسياج الشائك الذي نصبته
اسرائيل
هذا التصعيد سواء من قبل الخيمتين او من
قبل هذه الخط الاخيره باصابه عدد من
العناصر حزب الله باسلحه غير فتكه كما
قالت
نعمل الاصابات التي حدثت اليوم يعني يبدو
ان حتى
القذائف الاسرائيليه لم تكن قضائف قاتله
بمعنى انه
انها هي مقدمه لتصعيد واسع وايضا رد حزب
الله اليوم على لسان الامين العام
السيد حسن نصر الله بانه سيحقق في الموضوع
وبالتالي لا يبدو ان هناك سيكون رد من حزب
الله على هذه الحادثه وبالتالي هذا
التصعيد يبقى منضبطا في انتظار تطورات
معينه مرتبطه باولا
بالوساطه التي يقوم بها
او المستشار الرئاسي الامريكي اموس
هوكستان
حاول موضوع
الغجر والخيمتين المتعلقتين بمنطقه مزارع
اذا اردنا قراءه لا وراء او ما بين السطور
في كلمات الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني
السيد حسن نصر الله حينما قال ان احتلال
او ضم اسرائيل لجزء الشمالي من قريه الهجر
لا يمكن السكوت عنه وينبغي تحريره كلمه
تحريره هذه تعني الكثير هل تعني
جوله اخرى من الصراع على غرار ما حدث قبل
نحو سبع عشره سنه
نعم التوقعات بالتصعيد في المنطقه وارده
ولكن ضمن ضمن كما تحدث ضمن سقف معين لان
لا يبدو ان لا اسرائيل ولا حزب الله في
صدد يعني مواجهه شامله للمنطقه هي محاوله
تحسين الشروط وتحسين مراكز القوى اذا عدنا
لمنطقه الغجر هي منطقه محتله منذ عام 1978
هذا الاحتلال في عام 2006 الجديد هو
السياج الشائك الذي نصبته اسرائيل
وبالتالي كما قال
الامين العام لحزب الله ان الخيمتين جاءت
جاء نصبهما ردا على
سياج الشاي وبالتالي هناك شروط وشروط
متبادله في هذا في هذا السياق لو كانت
الامور مرتبطه فقط لكن لكن شهدنا تصعيد
واسع منذ فتره طويله لان الغجر ليست محتله
اليوميه محتله منذ فتره طويله كما قلت قبل
ذلك قبل ذلك ولكن لننتظر طبيعه الحسابات
المرتبطه في موضوع الشراع ولنبني على
اساسها سيكون هناك تصعيد واسع او
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كان معنا من بيروت
شكرا لك
نهايه الحصاد الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]